THEY DESTROYED HIS LIFE!
THEY OWE HIM.
MOLLIE, THANKS SO MUCH.
AFTER THE IG REPORT CAME OUT,
DURHAM ISSUED A RARE STATEMENT,
DISAGREES WITH SEVERAL PART OF
THE FINDINGS ESPECIALLY WHY THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION'S HAPPENED.
STEPHANIE GRISHAM FORMER
PROSECUTOR AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
AS YOU ASSESSED
>> THIS WAS A GOVERNMENT TRYING
TO OVERTHROW A PRESIDENT BY
FALSIFYING DOCUMENTS AND BY
LYING.
AND BY RUINING THE LIVES OF
MANY, MANY PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
WATCHING, YOU HATE TO HAVE
PEOPLE BECOME MORE CYNICAL THE
MORE NEWS THEY INGEST, BUT IT'S
HARD NOT TO HAVE THAT HAPPEN.
PEOPLE WONDERING, NO ONE IS
GOING TO BE INDICTED WHEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DESTROY
AMERICAN CITIZENS ON THE BASIS
OF NO EVIDENCE FOR POLITICAL
REASONS AND THEY GET AWAY WITH
IT?
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S BEEN A CHILLING EFFECT TO
SEE EVERYTHING TODAY.
WITH DURHAM, HE'S GOING TO LOOK
AT TWO
AT IWO
AT ITO
AT IT MORE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
ENFORCING THE LAWS OF THE LAW ON
THEIR OWN HANDS BUT NOT JUST THE
ONE FBI ATTORNEY WHO FALSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AGAINST CARTER PAGE
WHO WAS WORKING WITH ANOTHER
AGENCY.
ABSOLUTELY PEOPLE NEED TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S TROUBLING
ABOUT ALL OF THIS EVEN THOUGH AS
A REPORT CLAIMS, AND POLITICS
WERE BEHIND THESE SCREW UPS, IT
WAS A PURELY A POLITICAL SERIES
OF DISHONEST STEPS, THE FBI
REMAINS THE FBI WITH AWESOME
POWER.
PEOPLE ARE STILL GETTING
INVESTIGATE IT THE FBI.
CAN WE TRUST THE FBI IS A LEVEL
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION.
>> AS THE PRESIDENT SAID THERE
ARE GREAT PEOPLE WORKING IN THE
FBI, HARDWORKING PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE AT THE TOP LEVEL NEED
TO BE LOOKED AT AND NEED TO BE
LOOKED AT ALL THE TIME.
THEY HAVE GREAT POWER AS YOU
SAID SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE REALLY LOOK INTO THIS, WE
FIND WHO'S RESPONSIBLE AND THERE
ARE ABSOLUTE -- THERE SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: CONSEQUENCES.
DO YOU BELIEVE IT'S LIKELY THAT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL MR. BARR
WILL BE FIRING PEOPLE?
>> I HOPE SO.
I'M NOT GOING TO SPECULATE, BUT
I HOPE SO.
THIS IS A CHILLING EFFECT AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO
BELIEVE THAT THE FBI, CIA, ALL
THE INTELLIGENCE ORGANIZATIONS
IN THIS COUNTRY CAN BE TRUSTED.
THE FACT THAT FOR YEARS NOW
THERE HAS BEEN AN EFFORT TO
OVERTHROW THIS PRESIDENT?
IT'S SCARY.